it is super bowl week in
tampa as you mentioned as we've
mentioned all morning long it's tampa
bay hosting kansas city for super bowl
55.
you can watch the game sunday february
7th
on channel 8. and our live coverage from
tampa leading up to the big game kicks
off today
eight sports now's kevin martin is live
this morning at raymond james stadium
kevin good morning to you
as we get ready for the very exciting
super bowl 55. uh kevin
when we talk about the super bowl and
tom brady to the
tampa bay buccaneers he's not the only
tom with an impressive super bowl streak
let's talk about that good morning
well good morning john yes the countdown
the super bowl 55
is on here in tampa and everyone knows
about tom brady's unprecedented 10 super
bowl appearances
but what about tom henschel well this
tampa bay native
has put even brady's attendance to shame
this was the first one was in tampa
these are tom henschel's most
prized possessions this is in new
orleans it's when chicago bears beat
new england his tickets to every single
super bowl
he's ever attended all 54 of them so i
said after that third and fourth game
i am going to try and go to every game
and he has
since 1967. henschel is one of a select
few
who's never missed a super bowl the
feeling
and just the atmosphere like any great
streak in sports sometimes it requires a
little luck
which tom recalls was on his side a
couple times
first simple here i didn't have tickets
i ended up
starting for 200 dollars up i finally
had a man come up to me
he said i'll sell your ticket are you
serious give me 200 for my ticket
i said yes sir i wanted to close the
game so bad that was how close it was
a love for the game some serious
dedication
and a little luck has gotten tom
henschel this far
and the 79 year old plans on seeing the
streak go
a little longer than 40 game i i got to
go
trying to make 50. got to do it and now
here
i'm going to my 55th and i'm trying for
60 now
as you just heard luck was required on
several occasions to keep the streak
alive and
tom needed it again this year to secure
tickets during the covet pandemic
wasn't easy but on january 17th he
officially got word
from the nfl that he could purchase two
tickets for 2500
a piece a far cry from the twelve
dollars that he spent to get into super
bowl one
but tom said it was worth every penny
reporting live in tampa kevin martin
eight sports now
i love how you can look back and see how
it cost 12 dollars for him to go to the
very first super bowl that's just
how times have changed you look at like
the first halftime show and i think it
was the marching band from usc or
something like that so
crazy times uh kevin you've only been in
tampa for a couple of days it looks
chilly there actually this morning uh
what's the vibe like around tampa
leading up to the super bowl obviously
there have been a lot of precautions
yeah it actually is chilly you think
down in tampa it's sunny and you know
warm but yeah
it's definitely chilly this morning in
windy but the vibe i'll tell you what
tampa bay has done an unbelievable job
at keeping
the super bowl week festivities in the
atmosphere alive and electric yes we are
in a pandemic and yes they are taking
the
proper protocols as far as social
distancing mandating masks and
hand sanitizer stations all over the
city but they're also making sure
that the fans both local and ones that
are flying
in are having the experience of super
bowl week because i'll tell you what
it's a
once in a lifetime experience to be able
to you know
from monday through saturday join in on
these super bowl week festivities
aside from tom who's been there 55 times
in his lifetime
kevin thanks for checking in this
morning we'll catch up with you all week
long take care of yourself